Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the outside of the workshop, we've got another random experiment today
We're trying and this one is brought to us by youtuber elite fusion Z who asks
What does liquid nitrogen do inside of the backyard foundry Elite fusion Z? We think this is a great idea?
Well let's let the furnace heat up for a few minutes, and then let's open it up and once it's really good
And hot we'll pour in some liquid nitrogen and see what happens
Our furnace is getting nice
And hot I have a thermos full of liquid nitrogen and this metal cup that I'm going to use as sort of an intermediary
I'm gonna try a few different things first
I'm just gonna pour some liquid nitrogen from the cup down into the foundry
And then I'm gonna see what happens if I pour our liquid nitrogen into the cup and then carefully lower the whole cup full of
Liquid nitrogen down into the foundry as well. Let's see the difference quick note. I want to apologize for any background noise
There's some construction going on and you might be hearing some of the sounds from that
Alright a cup of boiling roiling liquid nitrogen well
Here goes nothing. I think it's just gonna make a lot of vapor
But I admit I don't know for sure
three two one
Huh
Check this out
So that bottom just turned black
And I think that's just because it cooled it down so much that it lost all its glow
Let's just pour a little bit more on and see if the same thing happens
So it just dissipates, but it definitely cooled that down enough that it lost its orange glow for a second
It doesn't take a ton either
So it definitely did something it cooled down the board. That's at the bottom of our furnace
But overall it wasn't very eventful
It just splashes in it dissipates very quickly
But it's so hot that you don't even see any of the vapors that you normally see rising off of liquid, nitrogen
Let's see what happens if we just put our whole cup full of liquid nitrogen down inside the furnace
All right, I'm gonna have to be pretty quick about this because otherwise it's gonna start burning my hand
But there we go three two one
That is some very actively boiling like no it's still cooling it down on the bottom
He's just the nitrogen vapors, and you can't see nearly as much flame
So I think the nitrogen vapor is filling up the furnace a little bit, and it's really subdue it
Mostly is just boiling away
Nitrogen is running pretty low
That cup has some very very hot parts and some very very cold parts on it
That's interesting because you know the bottom of that cup is still freezing cold
Even though the edges of the cup are now glowing orange
I think it's a steel cup so it should be fine, but hmm. It's a pretty thin walled steel
I'm amazed that any liquid nitrogen is still in there. That's very impressive to me that it's lasted this long
looks like we're just about out and
Gone, oh
And that is one hot cup and I'm just gonna splash some liquid nitrogen on it and see what happens
Well
I guess
From the point of view of liquid nitrogen this cup has always been super hot
I don't know. It's several hundred degrees hotter right now, though
No even the bottom of the cup is burning hot
once again not terribly remarkable the liquid nitrogen in the cup in the furnace it boiled faster than normal and
It did darken a little bit the bottom of this furnace
So it was clearly doing something there weren't as many flames as visible, but overall not a huge effect from liquid
Nitrogen in the furnace. There's a couple other variations. I want to try first
Let's see what happens if we have a cup of water in the furnace and we pour some liquid nitrogen down into that cup
All right, this is a cup of regular tap water
So that our furnace we get a little bit of that same darkening effect, just not nearly as much as with the liquid, nitrogen
Now we'll have to see how accurately I can pour using tongs and a metal cup from about a foot up
We'll try and pour this liquid nitrogen down into that cup of water
liquid nitrogen pouring into water
three two one
Well it certainly did something
There's still just a little bit of it on the surface of the water that water
At least part of it is boiling hot already that is the fastest I've ever boiled water right there
It's pretty nuts
Let's try it again
That does look pretty cool I
Think the biggest effect is that it?
Splashed a lot of the water out of the cup and that landed on the inside of the furnace
Well there you have it liquid nitrogen into the furnace not super exciting liquid nitrogen in a cup in the furnace
also, not super exciting
liquid nitrogen into water
In the furnace more exciting the water heated up very quickly and so I was pouring liquid nitrogen into boiling water
Surrounded by a ton of heat we did get a big plume of vapor coming off because of that
But it still wasn't anything that was really amazing so I think we need to scale this up to something a little bit more
Volatile we've tried freezing gasoline in liquid nitrogen before so now let's take a cup of liquid, nitrogen
Pour some gasoline into it till it freezes solid and then lower the whole thing liquid nitrogen and frozen gasoline
Down into our foundry see what that does I'm just gonna pour it from this cup into the liquid, nitrogen
Very thick white vapor comes off of that
Want a fair amount of frozen gasoline in there
This is gonna be a little bit of a set and run because the frozen gasoline does tend to be pretty volatile
So we'll see how this goes
The liquid nitrogen is still covering the frozen gasoline
So we might have to wait for a little bit of it to boil off before the gasoline ignites
Here we go
Well there's little specs igniting in the air
above the vapor of the liquid nitrogen this little kind of looks like fireflies or fairy lights or something oh
There we go
Hey now we have sort of a fire tornado and a furnace I
Think at this point. It's just burning a cup full of gasoline
Which is fun?
There's still some boiling going on on the surface
I don't know if any of that's liquid, nitrogen or if that's just pure gasoline in the cup at this point
That's a lot of thick black smoke. I'm gonna try putting the lid back on
What didn't help it at all
Fill the propane it's still gonna keep burning coz there's you know a cup of gasoline in there, but?
Yeah, still just boiling in there
It's now out
There is our cup that was full of liquid nitrogen and gasoline and now it's full of nothing
Well there you have it liquid nitrogen in a furnace not terribly reactive until you add gasoline of course
And then it goes about as you expect
It's kind of just like lighting a cup of gasoline on fire and a furnace which is pretty fun
I will push shouldn't have to say this
But don't try this at home partly because it's unsafe to burn cups low gasoline
But more so because it's really kind of a waste of liquid, nitrogen
There are a lot of more entertaining things that can be done with liquid nitrogen rather than pouring them into a furnace
Elite fusion Z
Thank you for your suggestion check your youtube inbox
We'll be sending you 25 bucks if you've got a great idea for an experiment
Let us know down in the comments, and if we use your idea for a video. We'll send you $25
Thanks for joining us for this experiment today and remember to come gear yourself up with products and merch at the king of random calm
See you there
This K wool was so nice and white when I started this experiment look at that, so there was now. It's all black
Hey guys
Thank you for your comments so many of you have really interesting
Suggestions for projects and experiments, and we love testing those out for you. I also wanted to say thank you for the great feedback
You're leaving for me and my team because we're all in this together, so thank you for being on our team